une question suit président merci
monsieur le préfet lors des déplacements
privés il ya t'il systématiquement où il
y avait-il puisque dans votre expérience
systématiquement un membre de la
chefferie de cabinet auprès du président
oui systématiquement soit le chef de
cabinet ce soit son adjoint sur les
déplacements officiels il y avait privé
vous avez alors sur les déplacements
officiels systématiquement sur les
déplacements privés très
exceptionnellement je vous remercie
madame marie pierre de la gontrie
merci président monsieur le préfet ma
question est simple quelques
connaissances
avez-vous aujourd'hui des fonctions
réelles qu'occupait monsieur benalla ce
préfet alors je vais parler de mes
fonctions après le j'espère après le
j'espère je les dis dans ma présentation
j'étais chef de l'unité de coordination
des grands événements au cabinet du
directeur général de la police nationale
et j'ai rencontré monsieur benalla à
l'occasion de l'organisation du sommet
de décembre 2017
ce mec c'est déroulé sur l'île seguin
sommet pour le financement des actions
de la cote clim mais pour eux pour faire
un raccourci
ce sommet a rassemblé une quarantaine de
chefs d'état du étrangers et donc en ma
qualité de d'experts dans l'organisation
pour la sécurité des grands événements g
j'ai eu à rencontrer monsieur bnl à
cette occasion il était le représentant
de la présidence de la république pour
l'organisation de ce sommet il a dirigé
plusieurs réunions la auquel j'ai
assisté en tant qu'adjoint au chef du
chef de cabinet ou chargé des missions
je ne sais pas exactement mieux tout
comme adjoint du chef de cabinet et nous
j'ai fait des missions de reconnaissance
sur l'île seguin sur le bateau mouche
qui ont utilisé les chefs d'état pour se
rendre sur cette île à ses côtés et son
positionnement était clairement celui du
chef de cabinet du président le chef de
cabinet adjoint du président de la
république